I'm going to jump across to Dominic
Robb's letter so he's read the report
that this is him highlighting what he
thinks of the fair points and the unfair
points in the letter that I think it's
fair to say it doesn't make him sound
like he's thrilled with the conclusions
and the Judgment of Adam Tolley but
since he pledged on Sophie ridges
program and at the start of this process
to resign at the moment that if he was
Phantom bullied or harassed anybody he
has gone and he says it's important to
keep my word
but here you go you've heard Adam
Tully's verdict on Dominic Royal's
behavior let's hear Adam let's hear
Dominic Robb's verdict uh on Dominic
Rob's behavior
um he's he points out that actually the
report didn't find that he behaved uh
badly in lots of different
types of ways so um ministers must be
able to give direct critical feedback on
briefings and submissions so a big part
of what we've just seen in the report
from Adam Tolley is he was
unconstructively critical to civil
servants who didn't turn up properly
Breeze he says you've got to be able to
do that if you're a minister you've got
to be able to tell your officials that's
not good enough go away come back this
is all in the Nuance this is all in the
disputed interpretations of what's
acceptable uh and what's not he says you
can do that provided Dominic Ram says
it's within reasonable bounds and then
he goes on to set out why he thinks that
although tough although tough it was
reasonable that report Mr Tony from Adam
toler's report concluded that I had not
not want in four and a half years sworn
or shouted at anyone let alone throwed
anything or otherwise physically
intimidated anyone nor intentionally
sought to belittle anyone I'm sorry if I
cause unintended stress however the
public expect ministers to push hard in
setting the threshold for bullying so
low this inquiry set a dangerous
precedent of spurious complaints against
ministers and that will have a chilling
effect on those driving change on behalf
of your government so overall
Sam you've got this sense that Adam
Tully has listed different types of
behavior and he has judged a couple of
them to go beyond what's acceptable a
kind of repetitive criticism of
officials that Adam Tully characterizes
as unconstructive and then Dominic
Robb's reply is look you've got to be
able to be frank with your civil
servants uh because in the end we need
to get the best out of them there is a
long way to run to see uh what side
everybody comes down on which is why
there is one verdict that matters more
than anything else we'll change the
screen again now we've got the letter
from the Prime Minister and I think
we're just going to go through this for
clues of where does Rishi see that come
down and I have a feeling that one of
the reasons it's taken so long 24 hours
to digest this 60 odd page report and
come to a conclusions because I think
inside Downing Street judging by what
I've read they feel that the whole
picture is quite nuanced what
constitutes bullying was there a group
of civil servants who never met Dominic
Rob uh working again against it so let's
let's just look at the language of the
Prime Minister uh he says it's with
great sadness I have accepted your
resignation remember the sort of
tributes to the Prime Minister brief and
Dominic Robbs a letter to uh receive
that but the other way around actually
it's very very uh uh a fulsome uh he
deals with the complaint the decision uh
to dismiss him at the beginning he says
when I became prime minister I pledged
that the government I lead would have to
have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every every level uh
the ministerial code requires ministers
to uphold uh the highest standards when
formal complaints about your conduct in
different ministerial poets were
submitted last year uh I appointed Adam
Tolley uh as you said you rightly
undertook to resign if any findings of
bullying uh were made whatsoever and you
have kept your word but it is clear that
there have been shortcomings in the
historic process that have negatively
affected everyone involved we should
learn from this how to better handle
such matters in future so that's the
Prime Minister talking about
um shortcomings amongst the people who
previously had made complaints but also
affected everyone involved does that
include is that a little note of
sympathy actually from the Prime
Minister acknowledging that actually
some of this stuff is more nuanced that
actually whilst there is unacceptable
verdict of unacceptable behavior in some
context there is some other context that
uh that makes the whole situation a bit
more complicated and then the rest of it
is essentially attributes to the uh four
sector Estate jobs that Dominic Robb has
done brexit secretary foreign secretary
and twice at the ministry of Justice uh
he says he was a great Justice secretary
putting victims and uh prisoners first a
great foreign secretary a key point in
brexit and uh uh and then taking on Hong
Kong and then uh pays tribute to that
role a lot of people remember that role
when Boris Johnson uh was prime minister
went into Hospital Dominic Rob took over
so where are we in conclusion I think
Sam that there are many elements of the
report that was done by Adam Tolley that
are pretty uncomfortable pretty damning
it paints a picture of something he was
pretty Relentless when dealing with
stuff but there's nothing physical cool
there was nothing outright there was not
outright shouting by Dominic Raab there
was something that critics and Adam
Tolley have judged with unacceptable
niggling at and effectively uh bullying
and undermining uh their confidence uh
something that Dominic Raab makes very
clear in his letter that he does not
accept amount of bullying because he
thinks that you should be able to have a
robust conversation with civil servants
who turn up without proper briefings and
the Prime Minister just a little hint
there that he's acknowledging that
whilst it was right to resign maybe this
situation isn't quite as clear-clutt as
you might uh have thought from some of
the headlines that there is a lot to
discuss in Adam tolley's report that
actually do have that group of civil
servants who never met Dominic Robb
working inside the ministry of Justice
effectively campaigning to get him out
it's not very straightforward actually
very positive about his grid this this I
think is a lot more sanguine a lot a lot
more traditional in terms of letters uh
to uh outgoing Secretary of State he's
had to resign uh pouring tribute on
everything they did so a verdict in
terms of his exit invert it a formal
verdict in terms of Dominic Robb's
Behavior but many many questions are
lots of people will end up taking away
lots of different lessons about all the
information the huge amount of
information that we've received this
morning I've been bringing to you on Sky
News